I don't know about you but I've noticed
a very welcome uptick recently in the
number of fantasy books inspired by West
African folklore the afrofuturism and
African futurism movements have paved
the way for Black authors across the
diaspora to build worlds and tell
stories influenced by their Heritage
thanks to the hit success of books like
Tomi adeyemi's Children of Blood and
Bone wider audiences are finally getting
introduced to the orisha and spirits of
yarabalor but who are these deities and
where do they come from
foreign
's novel the main character is part of
the iku clan that worships the deity Oya
and traditionally has powers over life
and death Oya is a real figure from
yaraba mythology a collection of stories
from the widespread tribe that speaks
the yaraba language Oya is one of many
orisha or deities who can move between
the human and divine Realms with control
over the wind a reputation as a fierce
Warrior and a responsibility to watch
over the threshold of life and death Oya
is one of the more formidable yaraba
deities but she is by no means the most
powerful according to yaraba mythology
the universe and all of the forces
therein were created by a single Supreme
Being most often known as olefin also
known as alaron or olodamare this
genderless Creator God is all-knowing
all-powerful and eternal it might be
tempting to compare olefin to the
abrahamic God but they are a unique
being and no other deity is like them in
the beginning of time oliphan crafted
the universe and invented day and night
they gave Divine energy called ashay to
all the objects and beings and breathed
life or Emmy into every living thing
they did not however want to manage
every living thing so oliphan created
the orisha to act as intermediaries
between Arun the spiritual Heavenly
realm and Aya the world of tangible
visible things there are hundreds of
orisha and yaraba folklore though it may
be impossible to give an exact count
because their characteristics are
malleable a single orisha's name gender
and parentage can vary depending on when
and where you hear the story though
their core traits remain largely
unchanged some of the orisha like
albatala and Aran Mila are primordial
figures who were involved in the
creation of the world others like odudua
or Shango were mortal ancestors whose
Deeds LED them to be deified into the
religion and there were many orisha who
personified aspects of nature like the
spirits who embody the numerous rivers
and lakes in the world before the world
was created olefin and the Arisha lived
in the sky around a young Baobab Tree
below them stretched a vast ocean ruled
by the Arisha olukun most of the orisha
were content to explore the sky and
enjoy a life of luxury around their
Baobab tree but abattala wanted more he
looked at the vast ocean below and
thought hmm I could make something with
that so he asked oliphan if he could
build a resting place for living things
oliphan gave him permission to make land
but left it to abatala to figure out how
albatala went to oranmila the orisha of
Prophecy for guidance Oran Mila whose
power of divination made him the sole
witness to oliphan's creation of the
universe told albatala to Fashion a long
gold chain fill a snail shell with sand
and gather a chicken and a date palm nut
a batala traveled the sky asking the
other orisha for their spare gold which
he forged into a chain to carry him to
alakan's Ocean when abatala climbed to
the end of the chain he found that he
still had some distance to go from his
position in the sky oranmila told
obatala to pour sand from his shell onto
the ocean and immediately drop the
chicken when it landed the chicken began
to kick the sand around until it formed
a huge landmass with Hills and Valleys
abatala jumped down from his chain and
planted his date palm nut which
immediately sprouted into a full tree
that spot became IFA the legendary
cradle of yaraba civilization that
archaeologists believe was an urban
center by 8 800 CE abatala made some
wine from the fruit of his tree and
after partaking in perhaps too many
Libations began to mold people out of
clay
many of the figurines were imperfect
with missing limbs or unintended bends
but allyfin breathed Emmy into them
anyway when abatala saw his Creations
come to life he vowed never to drink
again and assumed responsibility for
protecting humans with physical
differences in some stories avatala got
drunk before he could complete his task
of making land and his younger brother
the Arisha odudua took over for him
regardless of who made the land
yarabalor tells of odudua or odua the
first king of Etha from whom the yaraba
people are descended alakin was Furious
that her ocean had been encroached upon
without her permission not even a heads
up from abatala so she sent Great Waves
to flood the land those lucky enough to
reach high hills besieged eschu the
messenger orisha of roads and doors to
intervene on their behalf Ashu told
oranmila about the flood and he used
abatala's golden chain to climb down and
cast spells until alican's water
retreated notice that the people begged
eschu to take care of the flood not the
Supreme Creator as the messenger orisha
eschu stands watch at the boundary
between the Realms oroon and Aya the two
halves of the yaraba cosmos eschu
fairies notes and sacrifices Across the
Threshold and looks over ritual
practices according to a yaraba saying
if eschu is not acknowledged during a
ritual then life is the bailing of
waters with a sieve in other words if
you're not going to honor eshu why even
bother this makes even more sense when
you consider that eschu is the trickster
of yaraba Mythology ritual sacrifice and
prayer are just two of the ways mortals
can connect to the orisha's wisdom and
power the other is through divination
that lets humans see the universal
forces that influence their lives so
oranmila is the other orisha who sits
between orun and Aya as olefin intended
now I don't know from person experience
but any parent can tell you that just
because you give a being life doesn't
mean they'll always follow your
directions the orisha are no different
and in one yaraba myth they decided they
were tired of listening to oliphan what
could a being who lives so far away from
the world possibly know about how to run
it they believed they could do a better
job maintaining the world without
oliphan's pesky influence instead of
punishing the orisha for their
disrespect olefin held the reins back
from the world rivers and lakes
evaporated away crops withered and
animals and humans alike died of thirst
they cried to the Arisha as they had
always done when distressed what have we
done to anger you the humans never
imagined that it was the distant Creator
God who was causing their pain the
orisha begged for oliphan's forgiveness
but their cries couldn't carry far
enough to be heard many of the orisha
tried to reach oliphant's Heavenly home
but they tired before they reached it
beautiful Ash the youngest of the orisha
who looks after the world's Sweet Waters
wanted to try the other orisha was
skeptical that someone so young could
accomplish such a difficult task but
Austin insisted she turned herself into
a beautiful peacock and flew towards
oliphan's distant home as she flew her
feathers began to fall off and as she
passed the fiery Sun her feathers
smoldered away she flew and flew and
flew until she didn't think she could
fly anymore but she finally reached
oliphan by the time she collapsed at
their feet ashen's feathers were all
gone instead of a beautiful peacock she
was an ugly vulture oliphan was touched
by Ocean's Sacrifice by her courage and
persistence and agreed to send the
Reigns back to the world for her
troubles oliphan told Ashen that she
alone as a vulture could communicate
directly with them after this tale
humans can commune with the orisha
through eshu but anyone who wants to
reach Olivet must go through Ashen given
her beauty and proximity to the Supreme
Creator it's no surprise that Ashen was
one of the wives of Shango the woman
loving orisha of thunder and lightning
together they produced ibeji a pair of
sacred twins to this day twins are
special to the yaraba and mistreating
them is said to bring about Misfortune
in history Shango was one of the first
yaraba Kings who ruled from the ancient
city Oyo and was closely related to
odudua in mythology Shango is one of
many who sprang from the body of the
orisha yamoja the orisha Shango briefly
occupied the body of the Mortal King but
also took other forms throughout his
Immortal Life the human King shango's
Reign was harsh and violent Legend says
that he was so relentless in his search
for power through magic that when he
finally obtained dominion over thunder
and lightning he accidentally used it to
destroy his palace with his wife and
children inside dismayed Shango fled his
kingdom and hung himself but his mighty
power was not forgotten Shango was
deified as an Arisha after his death or
should I say that his identity as the
orisha was discovered after the King's
death either way King shango's Spirit
didn't follow the typical path of other
dead Mortals Someone who lived a long
good life could expect to join the
ancestors in oroon after they died if it
was part of oliphan's plan they might be
reincarnated unlike hinduism's karmic
reincarnation where a soul can return in
any number number of random forms based
on their behavior in a previous life at
unwe is the belief that you will be
reborn into your own family your actions
in this life determine your family's
future Fortune so if you misbehave you
won't come back as a cockroach you'll be
born into poverty as your great-grandson
these stories and beliefs from yaraba
mythology are a small part of a colorful
Dynamic culture that goes back almost 2
000 years they are preserved in ishay a
yaraba philosophy way of life and
religion which is still practiced by
many today there are roughly 50 million
people spread between parts of Nigeria
Benin Ghana and Togo who speak the
yaraba language yaraba and ishay
influence can be seen in Caribbean
spiritual practices like Santeria and
condom ble but now that you know a bit
more about atunway the intervening
orisha and supreme olefin I'm willing to
bet that you'll start to notice when
West African influence all over modern
media but believe me when I say I've
barely scratched the surface of yaraba
Mythology here so comment below with
your favorite stories or figures from
yarabalur and don't forget to thank eshu
before you hit send
before you go if you're a fan of this
show there is a new series on PBS
Origins called Rogue history that we
know you'll enjoy there is a mythology
surrounding pirates that has infiltrated
our culture but how much of it is true
Rogue history examines pirate lore to
unravel historical myths on Earth lost
narratives and introduce you to
little-known characters it's the pirate
history you were never told check out
the link in the description below